what happens
inside the pipeline function
in this video we'll look at what
actually happens
when we use the pipeline function of the
transformers library
more specifically we will look at the
centripetal analysis pipeline
and how it went from the two following
sentences to the positive and negative
labels
with the respective scores
as we have seen in the pipeline video
there are three stages
in the pipeline first we convert the
vortex to numbers the model can make
sense of using a tokenizer
then those number goes through the model
which outputs logits
finally the post-processing steps
transform those logits into labels and
score
let's look in detail at those three
steps and how to replicate them using
the transformers library
beginning with the first stage
tokenization
the tokenization process has several
steps first
the text is split into small chunks
called token
they can be words part of words or
punctuation symbols
then the tokenizer will add some special
tokens
with the model expected here the model
used expects a cls token at the
beginning
and a step token at the end of the
sentence to classify
lastly the tokenizer matches each token
to its unique id
in the vocabulary of the pre-trained
model to load such a tokenizer the
transformers library provides the
auto-tokenizer api
the most important method of this class
is from v-trade
which will download and cache the
configuration and the vocabulary
associated to a given checkpoint
here the checkpoint used by default for
the sentiment analysis pipeline
is distilled based encased fine-tuned
access through english
which is a bit of a morpho we
instantiate the tokenizer associated
with that checkpoint
then feed it the two sentences
since those two sentences are not of the
same size we'll need to pad
the shortcuts one to be able to beat an
array
this is done by the tokenizer with the
option padding equal through
with truncation equal true we ensure
that any sentence longer than the
maximum the model can handle
is truncated lastly the returned answers
option
tells the tokenizer to return a bi-dot
stencil
looking at the result we see we have a
dictionary with two keys
input ids contains the ids of both
sentences
with zeros where the padding is applied
the second key
attention mask indicates where padding
has been applied
so the model does not pay attention to
it this is all what is inside the
tokenization step
now let's have a look at the second step
the model
as for the tokenizer there is an auto
model api with a from retrained method
it will download and cache the
configuration of the module
as well as the pre-trained weights
however
the auto model api will only instantiate
the body of the model
that is the part of the model that is
left once the pre-training head is
removed
it will output a high dimensional tensor
that is a representation of the
sentences passed
but which is not directly useful for a
classification problem
here the tensor has two sentences each
of 16 token
and the last dimension is hidden size of
our model
768. to get an output link to our
classification problem
we need to use the auto model for
sequence classification class
it works exactly as the auto model class
except that it will build
a model with a classification head there
is one auto class for each common nlp
task in the transformers library
here after giving our models the two
sentences
we get the tensor size two by two one
result for each sentence
and for each possible label those
outputs are not probabilities yet
we can see they don't sum up to one this
is because each model of the
transformers library
returns logics to make sense of those
logits
we need to dig into the third and last
step of the pipeline
plus processing to convert logits into
probabilities
we need to apply a soft max layer to
them as we can see this transforms them
into positive numbers
but them up to one the last step is to
know which of those correspond to the
positive or the negative
level this is given by the id to level
field
of the model config the first
probabilities
index 0 correspond to the negative level
and the seconds
index 1 correspond to the positive level
this is how our classifier built with
the pipeline function
picks those labels and computed the
scores
now that you know each steps works you
can easily tweak them to your needs
you